welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your captain definition in this episode
we're going to be breaking down episode
7 of the cod our mission is to boldly go
where no one has gone before and give
our thoughts on the new entry as well as
what could be happening in the future
after Picard and Shoji finally came face
to face the series has started to wind
down and with just three episodes left
there's a hell of a lot to unpack
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the
seventh episodes plot it's Easter eggs
and what we thought of it as a whole we
will be engaging with heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the show yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way
thank you for clicking the video now
let's get into our breakdown of Picard
episode 7 episode 7 picks up with the
titular character and so Jesus cape from
the Borg cube the episode brings back
some familiar faces and it really makes
the entry feel like one of the most
nostalgic thus far
like all episodes we open in the past
and this time it's a flashback to the
daystrom Institute three weeks ago this
is the enigmatic mean between Commodore
oh and dr. Agnes Oh looks like she's
been watching nwa videos from the 90s
but either way these sunglasses must
have helped her to become inconspicuous
because it appears that she's been
stalking Agnes she details meetings that
she's had with Bruce Maddox and also
brings a powerful message last week we
theorized that the reason agnes killed
Maddox is because Oh had shown her the
dark secret that the shock bash know
about synthetics early on in the season
it was said that letting this secret can
break someone's mind and this is why she
decided to murder someone she was in
love with we see that theory come true
here without showcasing the annihilation
of what happened should synthetics be
allowed to exist so in her head Agnes's
mission is of the utmost importance and
Oh hands her a tracker using her as a
mole to find out what's going on in
Picard's mission in the present we jump
back to Rio Cinco who aren't having the
best of times they've been tracked a
lock to the ball cube and aborted
Nerissa is questioning Hugh as to
exactly what happened she doesn't mind
killing a couple of people to get
answers and the entire ship is in full
lockdown with narak heading out into
space to follow Rios in the group their
lap free from the tractor beam and
narrow
does his best Bubba Fett impression in
tailing them Nerissa really comes into
her own is the villain here and we do
know that she was very close to our at
some points so it could be possible that
she has been feeding her the visions
that she passed on to Agnes we did Co
herself in divisions so is likely that
this has been planted there by Nerissa
in order for the Romulans to achieve
their goals all know is left aboard the
ship and I did have a feeling last week
that he would be important here they
just randomly dropped him on the ship
right at the end of the episode and it
was obvious that they'd only done that
because they needed him to do something
in this episode and yeah they just had
no reason for why he would really be on
the ship I remember them doing this in
Man of Steel with Lois and depending on
whether you liked the show or not
probably will determine whether you
forgive this writing he is a very forced
arc on the ship I feel with him
discovering a plot device and yeah it
just feels a bit meh anyway after the
intro we jumped in a pente a forest
planet where were greeted by William
Indiana's child Castro Castro speaks for
Veen awhile language of the woods and
she's actually some deep ties to the
lore of star trek Diana's sister was
also called castra and she drowned when
she was very young it's a nice little
tribute that ties in well with Star Trek
law and shows just how much they're
thinking about the past of the show
she's an awesome addition and I'd love
to see a pop up in other shows down the
line you also learn that Castro's
brother died and William and Deanna have
been through some stuff Deanna has had
to deal with feeling the loss not only
herself but also the grief that the
others feel due to her abilities there's
a really heartbreaking moment in the
episode and this entry though quite slow
paced up points does indeed tick the
boxes in terms of character development
Castro leads them to the pair but along
the way Shoji almost has a breakdown
after realizing her entire reality was a
fabrication jean-luc calms it down by
telling her that assisted dodge was real
but just as she perks up he tells her
that she's dead which which was nice of
him he says so ever he saw a bad man in
this episode I will say that at Rancho
Riker we get to see a really nice catch
up Troy uses her extrasensory empathy to
pick up on the disease that is slowly
killing Picard but he assures her it's
gonna be alright
has made his house formidable and it's
the perfect sanctuary for Picard to hide
out and rest absolutely love this
reunion and it reminds us that the card
is truly strong because of his allies
and ability to make long-lasting
relationships with people that were
truly risk all for him
Castro questions Sochi and we learn that
she's a complete replication of a human
even down to her mucus data is hinted
towards being behind everything which
questions the theory of Maddux's
involvement we do know that data painted
a picture of dodging Sochi that showed
he did have designs for the girls but
who was involved as of now is still up
in the air
clearly Maddox was connected and I've
seen a ton of different fan theories so
I don't want to dive in and say which
one is wrong and which one isn't so yeah
I won't
rike it does figure out that Sochi is
connected to data though and it is going
to be interesting to see just where her
origin poles from exactly a borderless
arena they're trying to outrun Erik but
he's hot on their tails la serena
roughly translates to the mermaid and
sirens are of course myths that used to
lead sailors to their dooms this could
possibly be hinting at the fate of the
crew and the quote-unquote sailors
aboard it but i guess we will see as the
show develops Rafi notices that Agnes is
slowly falling apart and that she's
changed emotionally but it's not like
Ruffy didn't spend last week in bed
drinking anyway beyond building the
story jean-luc and Riker catch up I
remember the good old days I always
loved seeing characters that we once
knew as younger people age and it's
great watching people reprise their
roles throughout their lives Deana gives
Sochi a real tomato and she herself
comes to the conclusion that real is
better as she's only ever had food from
a replicator Shoji is of course a self a
replication but that doesn't mean that
she isn't real which i think is what the
show is dealing with we live in a world
in which many members of society are
viewed as being less than us because of
where they come from I think the show is
playing with the subtext of that showing
that no matter what makes us up we all
have the right to be considered real the
Star Trek episode measure of a man dealt
with is - in defining what rights we had
over others and it's nice to see this
aesthetic reappear here this talk of
that Deanna's child being fascinated
with homes and how they all connect us
and I think that this is the mess
being hammered home here he died because
of the sin ban and I love that Deanna
says real isn't always better it's a
nice little counseling session
appreciated quite a lot picaud gets a
scolding from Deanna and actually think
she shines the most in this episode
Marina Sirtis gets a lot to play with in
terms of dramatic beats and she's more
the intelligent aspect that really
cross-examines everything while Stryker
makes pizzas Riker also burns a tomato
which I see is sort of a nod to the
tomato from earlier and how real is
often weaker when you go through things
you are hardened and made in a certain
way that strengthens you and yep
replicators aren't always the best but
this new replicator is the best and if
you use the discount code in the
description below you get 10% off your
next daughter Eleanor a Marissa having a
fight aboard the Borg cube and she takes
out Hugh it's a big death in the show
and it kind of sucks seeing him getting
a very underwhelming exit I know the
scene was supposed to show how good
Nerissa was at fighting but happened so
fast for me that it kind of robbed it of
its emotional impact Raffi and Agnes
catch up and it seems like the latter
was trying to throw up her tracker which
as we learn is how narak is following
them she shut down the medical hologram
after killing Maddox and thus he's not
there though he does return later which
was was a bit confusing for me arias
suspects Raffy and tells Agnes about
this and he comes clean but he won't
really listen she does realize that
she's been doing bad things and manages
to disable the tracker herself using the
replicator that's sponsored this channel
I'll stop with her now the toxins in it
lead to her having a seizure and this
sensor into a coma Rio still suspects
Rafi and as she didn't explain this it
could lead to the two going head-to-head
in the next episode now last week we did
learn where Shoji was from and where the
nest of sins could be but no one really
seems to be looking for the planet all
that much after a quick text to captain
Karen Castro finds out where it is which
i think is where the rest of the season
will head off into Captain Obvious here
but yeah I don't know why the Romulans
are making this their top priority
around the dinner table picaud convinces
Shoji to trust him after she felt alone
and isolated he tells her of dodge his
fast data and how this mission has made
him feel alive in his office
Elmo finds the Fenris beacon that was
left behind last time and he reaches out
we know this is connected to seven of
nine and from the preview next week
she will be back Picard and Riker have a
heart-to-heart and it feels like a
farewell between the two I don't know if
it will be but Picard thanks him for
everything and but not trying to talk
him out of what will probably be the
character's final frontier they say
goodbye
Castro gives Shoji her crabby broken
compass and they head off now the broken
compass symbolizes that those Shoji is
lost it's still possible to find her
home and that she should go to where she
feels rather than what others are
telling her that's what I took from it
anyway and it lends itself well to the
subtext of the episode I really held
that this is the last time you see the
family as they I'm kind of worried that
the Romulans will show up and question
them and yeah I just don't want to see
them killed for not giving up Picard
anyway next week it looks like we will
discover the secret of the Jat bash and
we'll be getting a return of seven of
nine Agnes admits what is going on and
it looks like there's gonna be a big
showdown it's also a hint that seven of
nine may be reconnected back to the cube
and the emotional stakes are really
ramping up I can see everything coming
together next week and it's finally
learning why Shoji has been predicted as
the destroyer
we are still no closer to learning if
the bore Queen theory is correct but
hopefully we get a yes or no next time
as it's killing me
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Picard so comment below and
let me know if you enjoyed this video
then please drop a like and make sure
you check out our full playlist on
Picard which will be linked at the end
every month we'll give away free movies
to people who are subscribed to the
channel and this Monty can win the
nfinity saga box set and all you have to
do is comment on a video and make sure
you serve with notifications on the more
videos you comment on the more you have
a chance of winning so make sure you get
involved but when it's gonna be chosen
at random on the 15th of March it's the
best of luck that everybody takes part
you want to support the channel brahmans
little it's 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate it mister thank
you you get access to content early you
want to come chat us after the show
either follow us at Definition YT click
the discord link in the description
below those are the best ways keep up to
date with heavy
hopefully you see over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]